hello everyone another day another
lecture and you were here with my
youngest son got three of them this my
youngest one and he's on the other side
yeah we got new equipment so holy crap
but if something goes different or wrong
well you can hear me penny better yeah
okay well that's good oh we don't need
to use a horn anymore now I have to get
all close and personal with the miner
anyways what are we about well we we
generally talk against mathematical
physics we we don't like what
mathematical physics proposes as far as
physical interpretations okay that's
that's the important part it's not that
we're criticizing equations any of that
we don't care we think that science is
about giving explanations qualitative
explanations for how this universe works
and if we're gonna have irrational
explanations specifically the movement
of concepts they turn a concept into an
object called reification concretization
and you know if that's what they're
gonna do well then you know we've got
the worst of all possible worlds because
all their interpretations are bogus
and so what's pocus well you're just let
me run down real quick this is the
standard model of quantum mechanics
which is I'd say you could say it's a
third of the equation but I wouldn't say
it's a third it's almost half
and the other half his general
relativity then string theory is I don't
know a very small percentage and nobody
pays attention to string theory you mean
all the particles no no no general
relativity doesn't deal with this at all
so this is strictly quantum mechanics
this is what they came up with after
three thousand years of investigation
officially in the last hundred years
they came up with all these different
particles that's what they say they
found their seventeen official particles
there's more than 200 particles in
general that they found some they're
still looking for like the tachyon the
graviton that's why you don't see the
graviton in there looking for that
that's kind of mean it's like playing
there's no one you were taught in high
school okay
yeah in high school yeah it's dead yeah
I'm back
okay let's see if I get myself back here
yeah I guess I'm back can you see me
yeah okay I don't know you get a I hope
people refresh their screens yeah we got
interrupted CIA intervention here or FBI
one of those guys you know they
intervene maybe it was the mathematical
physicists they they you know try to
sabotage us I hope everybody can still
see okay so we're back just a glitch
there anyways I was saying that this is
the hydrogen atom that we have today
okay and that's the Beehive model all
those little electrons that's only one
electron supposedly but it said
everywhere at once that's what you're
seeing there okay and and there are
problems with this and here's here's the
main problem or one of the problems at
least the orbitals they turn to your
orbitals into physical balloons okay and
the orbital is the place or the region
in which you can find the electron and
one of the problems with this notion is
the if the electron is a little bead
that can be found anywhere around there
what they're really saying is that you
know this electron is going through the
nucleus and out the other end and of
course they just say well tunnels
through or they'll just say well the
electrons everywhere at once so they
don't have to justify why the electron
doesn't get stuck to the positive proton
you know want to go through the nucleus
because allegedly it doesn't go through
the nucleus it just pops on the other
side by a miracle and again it's all
hand waving it's all just
invention you know it's there's nothing
really there that you can sink your
teeth into it they just create whatever
they want that's it and you know they
ended up you saw this a couple weeks ago
we have the gluon springs okay and you
know the gluon is supposed to be a
particle and they really what they do is
they portray it is or represent it as a
spring to show why the quarks don't fly
away and there is no such thing is a
spring in the standard model here it is
again the standard model what does it
show it shows that the gluon which is
over here where the little G on the
upper right-hand corner that orange one
that's the glue on supposedly it's a
particle not a spring and okay so they
represent it as a spring to show why the
quarks don't fly away and they also use
them to show this which is when the
quarks fly away they stretch the gluons
until a new quark antiquark pair comes
into existence they're creating matter
from the void that's what they do and so
these are the explanations these people
have what do we propose instead well
here is a summary essentially I hope we
can see all of these parts you have
mathematical physics or quantum
mechanics on the left-hand side and on
the right-hand side you have the Rope
hypothesis rope hypothesis proposed it
that all atoms in the universe are
interconnected and you can see they're
right under the Rope hypothesis model
you'll see two atoms if you can barely
see them there they're connected by what
we call light in other words they're
connected by a rope and light is
essentially the torsion of that rope and
it can't get lost because it goes from
atom to atom the rope is in every
instance pulled tight and you know on
the bottom there you see what these
people have confused over the years
essentially and that's that they called
it an electromagnetic wave and what they
have been really describing
mathematically and otherwise is really a
rope in other words a two strand twine
the entity okay
in the realm of general relativity we
have something more fantastic still this
is the Big Bang
that's how matter originated okay there
was an explosion some 13.7 rounding out
14 billion years ago okay there was this
explosion supposedly they many of them
criticized say that it's not really an
explosion whatever but the point is it's
been expanding ever since created and
matter in the process they created the
stars it created the galaxies etc so
there was an origin to the universe and
one of the problems with that is that
there is no God to set it in motion it
just self started there you go it's a
creation without God creationism without
God and here's Brian green he shows us
what this universe looks like today it's
of what they call the block universe the
past in the future exists at the same
time in other words the future has
already happened it's deterministic in
the sense that you know you're just
walking on footsteps according to him
you know the everything you we can go to
the future that means the future is
already there all you have to do is go
from one of those slices that you see
those little lines there those are
slices of time and so as you move in
towards the right of the screen you're
moving forward in time and if you want
to see yourself when you're old or when
you die or whatever all you have to do
is go forward you know along that tube
there and you'll find yourself somewhere
in the future why why people from the
future don't come back to see us well
they say you can't travel back in time
you can only travel forward in time
great this is one of the problems with
the general notion of what these people
have come up with this is a picture of
space-time which is the bread and butter
of relativity relativists then denying
it but this is how they explained
gravity they say you know essentially
there's a bowling ball sitting in the
center of a canvas pushing it downwards
by force by Newton's
and that creates a warpage and then
everything falls into the hole and
that's supposedly that attraction is
what they call gravity and can you
imagine space-time no it looks something
like this like a tesseract I don't know
if ours is cubic like this or spherical
you know they're they've got different
things but they say you cannot even
imagine it and of course you cannot
imagine it because what they've done if
they blended space space with time you
might have trouble with space but
certainly nobody can have trouble with
time time is a concept and if you in a
cisu meaning that space is is a physical
object let's talk about a rock
you can't put Rock with time and create
a rock time a four-dimensional Rock time
that's what these people are doing ok
rock times time to rock rock and here we
have the space-time bottle that you'll
see this is this is what they finally
came up with this is what our universe
looks like it's that bottle their time
is all those white lines that cross the
bottle and you know those are
cross-sections of time and the bright
spot on the left that's the start of the
universe 13.7 billion years ago
ok I don't know why they have you know
on the right hand side I don't know why
they have it ending because supposedly
that's the present because they always
measure that and they say it's 13.7
billion years ago to the present but the
problem with that is that you know since
you can go to the future in the future
already exists a block universe is a
better representation of what they're
talking about they're saying the future
already exists so they shouldn't stop
the bottle there but they do and they
get away with that like they get away
with everything else well what has
relativity come up with it's come up
with the guarding of the present of
contemporary general relativity which is
the black hole and here you have the
black hole now as you can see they say
well you know what is a black hole black
hole is a region in space-time and you
can see it's moving right but what is
the problem the problem is as you can
see the
hole is a hole in space-time or in space
and whatever that thing is that blue
thing that's in the background right but
the problem is that you know the way
they explain that the creation the
formation of a black hole starts when a
star collapses on it because of
gravity's got it suffers a gravitational
collapse so it's strengthened shrinking
shrinking shrinking it's a standalone
object right
it shrinks so much that it becomes a
region of space-time of something else
it's like if you have a rock in your
hand right just imagine this for a
second
the rock is shrinking shrinking
shrinking shrinking becomes the palm of
your hand or what are the lines in your
you know it becomes a region of
something else that's what a black hole
is that's where the surrealistic part
comes in and finally here we have the
parallel universe they've created
something called the wormhole the
wormhole is allegedly you know when you
go into a black hole you end up going
through this tube that goes from one
universe to another or from one part of
space to another and it's kind of like a
tunnel one dimensional tunnel if you can
imagine this here it's a
three-dimensional one that I have to put
in there because I can't put I can't
draw one dimensional things
I'm just not qualified as an artist to
do that and you can see when universe on
the right I don't know that you can't
see it very well but there is a universe
on the right there's another one on the
left right and these universes keep in
mind include space-time to matter so the
question is what's the black stuff
through which the wormhole is going
through you know and that's that's the
surrealistic part here yeah and all the
other stuff that these people have
created is all so realistic it has no
validity whatsoever in the realm of
rationality and we define rationality in
the last few weeks and the main one
again you know is converting concepts
into objects and then begin to move them
around and before I accept that I'll
accept Christianity Islam
Hinduism Buddhism I'll take any of those
over what these people are proposing I
think you know all these traditional
religions are a little more rational
than what is coming out of mathematical
physics what do you think good summary
real crash course so that pretty much
that's it the last one is I never
touched this subject very much
I think it's total nonsense string
theory there's some mathematicians out
there that got bored and tired of doing
particles in quantum and the simple
stuff of general relativity you know you
have a point in space-time it's called
an event many events make up space-time
they got bored with all that they say
okay we know all the mathematics over
there we know the mathematics over here
let's invent a new mathematics and what
they've been bettered is strain theory
which is an attempt to unify general
relativity and quantum mechanics
specifically they're interested in
unifying gravity they can't figure
gravity out and the equations that they
develop for general relativity don't
match those in quantum and the ones in
quantum are really in existent they
don't have any equations that are valid
except you know particles going back in
time or or particles attracting
particles delivering negative momentum
you know I mean nonsense total nonsense
mathematically you can represent it you
just put a negative sign you got
negative force fine physically you can't
do it in the lab and you know and then
again quantum is a force or investigates
force and general relativity has gotten
rid of force Newton's force they use the
Warped canvas you know warpage of
space-time geometry that's so the how
they're gonna reconcile these two
divergent theories I have no clue and I
don't think they do either so yeah
that's where we're at
and what we do usually is who we we look
up questions in Cora where a lot of
people you are interested in finding
answers to some of their question per se
qualitative type answers and sometimes
you'd be surprised what kind of answer
you really find in there you know from
the specialist there's a lot of
questions in Cora's questions oh oh they
ask you about celebrities about the
people who maybe far-fetched
just kind of to know like hey if we
[Music]
guess teleportation you know and again a
lot of this has to do with a mixture of
of general relativity of concepts that
they've developed in irrational concepts
right that they develop in general
relativity and others that they develop
in quantum in quantum supposedly you can
tunnel and you can be everywhere at once
you know the field is everywhere the
wavefunction is everywhere the what is
it the probability wave as they call it
what is that it's everywhere okay so
that's the wave that's the field okay
that's on the quantum side and you have
tunneling you have mysterious
entanglement where this particle over
here can affect the one over there so
they have all that magic there that
they've never explained they just said
well that's the way it is that's the way
the real universe works that's quantum
general relativity on the other hand you
know they say well you know we have
wormholes you can tunnel through them to
another universe so people kind of like
that and so when you put all these
thoughts together yeah they come up with
teleportation was a time traveler no the
other one I was thinking
you know beam me up scotty teleport you
okay yeah you know so they have all
these magical things where you're
instantaneously transported you're over
there well yes I'm TV in Hollywood they
can do this yeah all of this stuff they
can teleport you they can do whatever
they want with you in tango man they can
do everything
the problem is doing that in real life
and what these people are claiming is
that they can do it in the lab like at
the particle level that they have
entanglement no what they tell you is
look we observe something that we don't
understand and we notice that this which
we're assuming to be a particle effects
this other guy over here which is also
assumed to be a particle and so they
said look this particle effects this one
and that's just of a feature of reality
okay and so that's that's where it all
comes from now and that's what they say
we proven it in a lab they haven't
proven anything they haven't proven the
theory because they don't have a theory
they don't have an explanation what they
have is a description they call that a
theory and they say oh we proven the
theory what they say is that we verified
that this happens in the lab whatever is
that's happening in that invisible world
and yes if you assume that you're
dealing with particles which is a very
important assumption then you know I
mean it's critical if we're not dealing
with particles then all that's nonsense
although quantum is nonsense but yeah if
you assume that you're dealing with
particles then you won't be able to
explain how this particle effects that
one over there instantaneously or
otherwise and and that's one part of it
then the second one is that you know you
need a mediator and if you don't have a
mediator then yeah you're gonna
rely on magic and that's why at what
quantum has today it's got what they
call quantum magic we seem to have a lot
of magic yeah the question then becomes
to what extent do explanations of
physical phenomena affect someone's life
like to what extent does knowledge of
physics affect a person's life first
it's not knowledge its I want to
distinguish explanations from
terminology and that's the first one we
need to explain and if we can't explain
you you can say well does that affect my
life you know is my life affected in any
way and I'm saying you know science is
not the purpose of science is not to
affect you you know in your daily life
you work at the quarry you work at the
mine you work at the office does knowing
the quantum world or the general
relativistic the macro world does that
affect you in any way no it's just now
it's for now let's say Q we're gonna
talk about knowledge or explanation for
explorations sake you say okay now I see
a different kind of universe does that
change your life in any way in a sense
of what you live daily no because
ordinary physics we're still dealing
with classical physics so if you want to
know how a pulley works why you can run
so fast or whatever you know that that
part we've resolved we have all the
equations for that and we have rational
explanations we don't need to convert
concepts you know someone breaks my
window I don't say Oh energy came
through the window no I don't say that
I'd say a rock came from a window and
everybody can understand then that's
straightforward so that part we all
understand we have no problem you bump
against the wall you say my shoulder hit
the wall you don't say
energy was hit with so much force in so
much mass you don't talk in those terms
so it doesn't affect us in that sense
and in our daily lives where it does
affect us is in our in the way we
perceive the universe in the in our
conception you know it's it's only for
thinking it's only for
food for the mind like oh how
interesting this universe works this way
it works that way that's all it is it
doesn't help us develop technology I
don't think it does at least it might
give you some clues to something maybe
but it doesn't affect us in any way in
our real lives and that's why that's why
these people can come up with anything
at this point because it nobody cares
because it doesn't affect their daily
lives if it affected them I better
believe that they would be interested
but nobody's interest went up when they
were wrong right if that's right no no
yeah in the old days you know when the
astrologers failed to predict they were
executed the King would have officially
went he lost the war or the battle
whatever he would take that astrologer
and hang him he said you were no good as
an astrologer
if these guys we could hang the
mathematicians for the the weird things
that they say out there then maybe we
get some rationality introduced back
into you know science but as long as
there's no loss as long as there's no
accountability say anything right
because it doesn't affect our lives and
let me let me give you a limited point
you always talk about physics really
just being for fun or for them not
really for any use and I think that's
kind of the nail in the coffin for that
statement because I mean that basically
kind of proves it at least to me okay
the physics is just it's just root for
your mind it's just for fun it doesn't
affect your life because if it did yeah
and and you know I worked as an engineer
for many years and you know when you
work in a production line like I did and
your line gets stopped because there's
something wrong in your operation you
know maybe the machine went down maybe
you got some back flow from the vacuum
pumps you're putting dirt and I work in
the semiconductor industry so we make
chips and
you know you have tons of garbage on top
of your wafers well you're in trouble so
so they stopped the line and you stopped
a line that is worth millions of dollars
so at that point you got to fix the
problem because every second count
time is money okay and so now you so now
you're putting your your reputation your
knowledge everything on the line your
salary your job maybe you got to go to
another job because you couldn't fix the
problems there you know so when you work
on a line you're responsible for making
sure that line goes through so an
engineer cannot come over and say you
know some energy fell on my wafers and
it has so much mass and it hit the wafer
with so much force now we don't talk
like that not in engineering forget it
there you have to talk about particles
that you can see that you can put in a
Sam scanning electron microscope or
atomic force microscope they have these
days you got to see the particle you got
to say oh I got a particle there where's
this coming from
you got to analyze you got to find out
you know there's a process known as OJ
machine and you analyze it and tell you
what the particle is made of you guys go
through all these steps to try to figure
out you know where that thing is coming
from correct a problem get to the line
back I you know if we could do that in
in theoretical physics it'd be great
because now you know we stopped the line
right and so the theoretical physics has
to fix the line you know the lines
aren't producing anymore but that's not
the case you know there's no involvement
least in theoretical physics you can say
anything you want because there's no
accountability
[Music]
explain uh-huh and I don't think that's
the end or the final purpose of physics
what if you always say this is
explaining relax is physics is about
explaining right yeah but you kind of
end it there but I think he goes a step
further with the purpose of physics
because Oh explanations you like let's
say you want to know how a magnet works
right okay you get a list of
explanations all the possible ways you
could explain the phenomena of magnetism
and that's not physics yet I think
physics is when you narrow it down to
the one with the least flaws I think the
purpose of physics is looking for the
explanation that has the least flaws
it's it's it's one step for it's not
just explaining with whatever
explanation you can like just take the
first one you can come up with I don't
think that's that is physics
I don't think physicists just it's
explaining and eliminating process of
elimination is weeding out all the ones
it's kind of choosing in a way I mean
yeah you always bunch that up in the
religion thing where okay this guy
thinks that this is the real explanation
of how magnets in or if this guy thinks
is that one we're not interested in
which one ever takes but I think I like
angels yeah I think the choosing is is
the whole point of why we do physics in
the first place is to have the the
flawless explanation to every phenomena
that we can come up with because it's
almost as ghosts yeah okay you have an
explanation but it's not it's very
flawed so it's like it kind of leaves
you unsatisfied know you know and I
think a lot of mathematical physicists
also feel that way with yeah they don't
like that theory the ghost theory or
their own I think a lot of mathematical
physicists or people working at CERN
just like they kind of have this theory
as a Jochen
that's what we have with the rest we
have but it still has a lot of flaws
right and yeah you can see this
opportunity like oh we can that gives me
room to figure out these flaws so you
know I can get the Nobel for a figure
out these flaws but at the same time
maybe they're also like man it'd be so
much it'd be so cool if we could find a
real answer to these things if we could
see the invisible world if we could
actually make sense of all this right
and making sense of something is the
purpose of physics and you can't make
sense of something if you just take any
explanation yeah but you know what's
happened ever since Niels Bohr I think
he really screwed up science for good
you know they came up with not only
Niels Bohr but Werner Heisenberg and Max
Born and so on all these people Chadwick
all these people who were working in the
20s and 30s they came up and they said
look forget about what we used to do in
the 19th century and before that was
classical we came up with quantum
mechanics and and what's the issue the
issue is that they changed the purpose
of science especially the purpose of
physics and they said look the purpose
of physics is not to explain how this
universe works it's to describe it and
and we cannot put into words you know
what mother nature does out there all we
can do in other word we can't put into
words our mathematics our equations it's
like two separate languages one is the
language of the Klingons the other ones
the language of Earth you can't bring
the language of the Klingons over here
and say look this is what these guys are
saying or this is their theory or
whatever you can't do that they say it
can't be translated they say there's
there's no in fact Niels Bohr said when
dealing with quantum words can only be
used as poetry you know you can't really
go out there and say you know you know I
can take this equation and put it into
words in such a way that when you
look at the words you say oh I
understand exactly what the physical
interpretation with the process that's
going on in there is he says you can't
do that all we can do it in again and I
think and I think the bottom line here
is if you look at what he's saying there
he said no I can't turn a description
into an explanation and yeah I agree you
get there you can't turn an equation
into words because equation is that this
is a mathematical a quantitative
description I think it has yeah which is
this like idea there isn't completely
fleshed out yet or this precise
definition like the notion for love we
all kind of kind of know what it means
and I think what they're doing the
reason why they can't or what they think
they can't turn mathematics into our
languages we don't have the notions in
in our language that they've come up
with with mathematics we don't it's like
it's like they've come up with new words
that have to be made up yeah believe me
believe they came up with a new language
superposition if you think I do
semantics you should listen to them talk
they're they've invented all kinds of
stuff specially when they use words you
know the famous cases one that we've
been discussing last couple weeks
whether you use the word particle and
particle is not a particle no not what
any normal saying you know human being
rational human being says when he says
particle particle means something
totally different in quantum but they
use the word particle they illustrate a
particle but they don't mean what they
wrote and they don't mean what they said
a particle is a field and it's described
with the wavefunction which is an
equation that tells you where the field
meaning the particle is so they're
talking about where it's at and how it
extends and then they can't draw for you
a particle
but that's what they do they draw a
particle they draw a little dot a little
circle little ball whatever they draw
and they call it a particle you say okay
I understand then I know what a ball
looks like you know and this is a little
ball a little dot okay clear to me
that's not what they mean and what they
really mean is something else they say
look what you're staring at is an
equation and it's an equation of where
the particle is and so it's it's a weird
twisting of the language and of the
sense of what they're trying to convey
to you because they they keep going back
and forth between the particle the real
particle the dot the little ball and the
fact that it was not really a ball it's
an equation that describes where the
ball is at and because it's a field it's
everywhere at once and so what have they
explained they have this irrationality
built into their language already you
know or they tell you something like you
know what's uh what's space-time and
they say it's a mathematical object now
what the hell is a mathematical object
there's no such monster either it's an
object or it's mathematics but a
mathematical object it means they're
pulling uh you know they're selling you
some kool-aid you know that's what it
means
[Laughter]
we don't do philosophy but yeah well we
do science and philosophy we said as
part of science I guess some philosophy
is acceptable by default yeah but
remember it's not really philosophy when
we talk about theories of physics well
yeah let's clarify that when when we
talk about theories of physics you know
people you have to get into what is
called what is traditionally been no
his ontology metaphysics philosophy you
know we're saying no we got to separate
those things we have to define
philosophy in a rational scientific way
that we can use consistently and if
philosophy is going to be at least one
of the two branches of science and one
that deals with concepts the one that
deals with reasons and purpose then you
know it's it's a branch of science it's
not over science it's not over physic
it's just a separate branch of science
this is the antithesis right and if we
look at it that way at least we can use
it consistently but if we're gonna say
philosophy we didn't never define the
term I mean we start saying well it's a
the accumulation of knowledge and we're
trying to figure out how this universe
works and within philosophy I guess it's
a it's a so if you use any of these we
have a list not a complete list but I
have a pretty good relation of most
wanted if you use any of these words
please define it first
forget forget all the categories right
just very simple we have a list of words
if you're gonna explain anything to a
kid to yourself to anyone if you use
this word you got any of these words
watch out because there's a high chance
that you haven't thought out what this
word means yeah and one of the problem
with that is that you know people don't
like to get into that because they say
oh that's ontology oh that's uh what is
it semantics philosophy or what are they
dismiss it because they say well yeah
let me tell you my theory no no I don't
want to listen to your theory I'm not
gonna listen to it until you define
these terms because otherwise I'm not
gonna understand your theory so please
define the terms before you continue and
to make
get Rock extremely precise what I mean
by defining a word is giving the
criteria by which you name something
that word if you use this when do you
use this word when these criteria are
met what do you call this word when
these criteria are met looking for
criteria to use a word that's how that's
the the clearest way of defining of
knowing whether you're using a word
right yeah and but anyway the Safa cool
question I already yeah I'm going to be
in the way we use the word which is
concert concepts of purpose or reasons
reasons is why do you think the ego is
so interlinked with science and
knowledge and explanations like people
always get defensive or people always
get highfalutin and it's always there's
always a little extra it's never just
like robotic science you know it's
always science with a little bit of
there's always there's always this this
this these emotions when it comes to
like intelligence and things like that
what do you think that is well let's
start at the beginning and I know and
I'm asking that knowing you're not
you're not you don't think about
philosophy let's start you know how did
God start the universe at the beginning
okay so let's start in the beginning
okay in the beginning there was Buddhism
Hinduism Islam Christianity and who
knows how many religions more out there
and one religion laughed at the other
religion they said look at what this guy
believes in and so they made fun of each
other they had wars you know for
interest etc and it's just different
parts of the world developed religion in
different ways and not all of them had
the same concepts but pretty much if you
look at history you know the way a lot
of these religions develop you will see
that their origins were very similar the
first they started talking about the
wind and stuff that they could see the
Sun you know they turned all those into
gods then they eventually converge more
or less into you know one God so we went
from polytheism to monotheism
and and then we ended up with something
worse which is mathematical physics yeah
and what is it all about what it's about
you know my religion against your
religion so it's like you're touching
you're touching my god you're raping my
virgin that's a good point
even with way back is religion they're
killing each other I mean forget ego
this is this is the extreme version of
ego if people die for for what we
explained earlier that's really just fun
and and just for yourself just for your
mind just just just while you're
drinking a coffee but it got more the I
know it goes beyond the way beyond this
it's not all just fun and games that
we're talking about here or at least
that's what it should be but it isn't
yeah because it's yeah you just said it
perfectly there people die over their
beliefs they killed for their beliefs
and uh yeah I think it's just human
nature in many ways that people want to
be right or you know in their own minds
you know here you have an individual
right and in his mind he says okay I
understand how this world works it works
this way we have Zeus over there we have
Hermes over there okay it's perfect for
me I understand it perfectly and you
come across another guy you know he's
from Africa maybe or maybe oriental guy
and you say see look does this and here
you have you know Apollo he drives his
chariot every day you know from one side
of the Flat Earth to the other side of
the Flat Earth and goes around you know
and the guy looks at you says oh no you
know the universe doesn't work that way
or the earth doesn't work that way look
there is no such thing as Zeus there is
no say are you saying I'm a liar
are you sings I'm stupid this is it so
it's like it's like you're putting your
fingers up my nose and you're saying
what you're saying I'm a prank so it's
like you're offending the guy because
you're offending his you're raping his
virgins is it so wrong to be wrong
that's the question why is it so
wrong why is it so bad because it means
that you spent all your life thinking
about this truth that you can put your
hand in the fire for it someone tells
you truth what are you talking about all
of what you believe in on what you're
preaching are lies
and they're guys not gonna accept that
he says coded all my life you're saying
that I did all this investigation
I heard all these versions I listened to
the priest on Sundays and I've got this
good idea of how this world works you're
saying all of it is wrong and you get
you're gonna brush it all over aside
that they that Alton my priest was wrong
all the all the Catholic Church was
wrong the Pope is wrong how can they all
be wrong so yeah it's like you grew up
with all this you you may be your family
educated you that way to begin with and
so you grew up with this religion in
your mind and when someone attacks at
your beliefs saying you know all this is
is nonsense then now you're offending
the person because you're saying you're
an idiot
you're a prank you're crazy you should
be locked up with culture and deep human
nature of identity when someone we're
talking about what you grew up with your
family and your beliefs but police is
such a weird education education but I
mean I get the other ones but I really
you think with at least the beliefs that
don't affect your life yeah but I think
what it is is that people are
essentially saying that you are stupid
that that's what that's what comes
across it's like saying you believe in
this you know I think a lot of people
think of them or 90 percent at least of
the humanity takes offense to that I
mean just just do the experiment go to
the East different culture right in
general go to I don't know Philippines
or Thailand and you know and you'll find
Buddhists and they have there
temples and all then just go in one of
those places say you know I think
Buddhism sucks what do you think they
would do over there I think you said the
Buddhists don't kill I never saw a
Buddhist that killed no there were no
wars in Buddhism yeah there were warned
not only were there I mean Japanese they
grew up primarily with Buddhism and they
were a warrior class you know what were
all these Shogun's and so on they were
Buddhist and they killed each not only
each other what the China killed the
Chinese turn the other cheek they pulled
out their swords yeah but see because
these religions including mathematical
physics they're ingrained very deeply
into people people who you know who go
to college and study a lot of this they
essentially get brainwashed into quantum
and general relativity and they
eventually accept that as common
knowledge as as you know a second nature
and so so they don't have a problem with
it and when someone confronts them
saying what the universe is flat it's
four dimensional you know some of the
things we just mentioned a minute ago
particles which are really concepts you
know there are mathematical equations or
fields or or you know wave functions or
whatever and you start criticising
you're telling me I was it went to the
university I got a degree in this you're
saying that I'm wrong although all the
mathematicians on planet earth are wrong
specially when there's so many yeah I
guess it gets bad with population and
then and then you know that you're not
criticizing physics you're criticizing a
religion because now the guy is not
willing to analyze he's just willing to
repeat what he learned
College and he just recites it and so
now you're talking to a zombie you're
not talking something to a rational
individual who can rationalize something
that he can't he can't it's it's common
knowledge these people will tell you
that they can't rationalize what's
happening out there they just say oh we
proven it we verified it in the lab
here's the equation but they cannot
explain how it happens they say well we
don't care about the explanation and so
when you ask them a qualitative type of
question say well please explain how
unwilling works they say we can't
explain and science is not about
explaining science is about describing
and that's where they shut you off and
and you're in you're stuck because these
guys are the guys who run the the show
in science what does it take to change
your belief well I think torture does it
you know I know that for example when
they got a hold of Martin Luther they
said recant and the guy said well you
know I can't recant and and he was saved
they would have killed him they would
have burned him alive you know like they
did with John Huth for example in in
Prague you know they burned him at the
stake and because he wouldn't recant
someone changing your beliefs about you
changing your beliefs because at one
point you didn't investigate all of this
and you just kind of thought oh someone
knows about ya you III went through a
path of discovery all on my own I went
through the jungle my own machete and
started you know making my own path and
that's why you know I got lost in the
jungle cutting and you got to my own
change you believe ya searching and
that's why I always say the best way to
to I mean if you're really not stuck to
your religion whatever you were born or
educated with and you know you really
want to find out how this universe works
well then you go with your own machine
and the first thing you do is you raise
the board everything that's out there
just assume that everything you know is
is bogus right and so you start over you
clean the board you say okay let's start
at square one what is light what is
gravity well you know or whatever
wherever your starting point is and you
start doing your own search and and you
listen to different people and this guy
has this idea this guy has that idea
then you start forming your own idea and
I think that's the only way that you can
really come up with your own religion
your own set of beliefs that you can
really you know that you're strong on
because other is otherwise they
otherwise all you're gonna be doing is
memorizing what other people have
already you know they swallow the
kool-aid now they're giving it to you
and you're just wanting the kool-aid
instead of that if you go out there and
do your own research and say well let's
start by erasing the board let's start
all over that's where you are gonna run
into trouble because you know people are
not gonna accept that they're gonna say
but you're saying that well we did 2,000
years all this all this foundation that
we created you're gonna dismiss it yeah
let's erase all of it let's start all
over and you know the mathematicians are
not willing to do that they're saying no
no I took all these courses in the
university I got a PhD
there's too much investment yeah there's
too much invested so they're not going
to you raise the board they're not going
to start at that point is that so maybe
that's for me let's see what is space
different things that it could be I
thought it was gonna be a difficult
question but I got a one-liner I can
answer the top the first answer they
came up his space is a term that can
refer to various phenomenon science
mathematics and communications if he mr.
Donavan cosmology let's just take that
one yeah this base is the vast
three-dimensional region that begins
where the Earth's atmosphere ends
well I got a much shorter answer space
is nothing that's it sorry that that's
the definition space is nothing I define
it as that which doesn't have shape
because something is the opposite of
nothing
there are antithesis these two words are
on the opposite side of the spectrum so
if something is that which has shape
nothing is that which doesn't have shape
we should have a word for nothing we
caught space because that's what all the
matter out there is floating in nothing
there is there there is no box there is
no no edge to space and I don't have to
go to this well it's not infinite
because infinite is an adjective that
can only be applied to objects and an
infinite object is irrational because
all objects are finite so the word
infinite is an irrational term anyway
you look at it for the purposes of
physics okay and what they're saying you
know the mathematicians they are really
talking about incessantly they talk
about motion and they called that
infinite or they talk about infinite
numbers and what they're doing is
counting incessantly and they call that
infinite numbers or infinity or whatever
they use there so the point is that
there's no infinite object and you can't
say that a concept is infinite and
nothing space is a concept nothing is a
concept it's that which doesn't have
shape and you can't say nothing is
infinite you can say that an object is
infinite if there were such a thing like
the block universe I guess that would be
an infinite object but you can't say
that about space space is nothing
it might have to do with the fact that
we never think of it in those terms or
has never been passed on or educated or
talk to us in those terms or say like
just the concept of nothingness yeah I
know I think it's very hard to picture
this yeah because the whole point is you
can't teachers right there's nothing
there
I like picture love or information or
intelligence what are we talking about
you know can you make a picture of it no
you can't because it's a concept and
likewise you can't make a picture
there's nothing but this one's weirder
because we have this sense nothing
exists I mean what I usually do when I
picture things as you can like zoom in
zoom out and see the shape yeah but when
you have like let's say two chairs right
and you're trying to imagine the
nothingness between domain their space I
don't man zoom in zoom in it's like how
much nothingness is there between these
chairs and you can't talk about how it's
not how much nothingness well you know
nothing to count yeah the the
mathematicians have eventually concluded
that space is made out of particles and
they bring them in and they're chambers
and they're known as virtual particles
that pop in from the void and go back
and form the nothingness of space and
you know fellow my friend I said
something this got to be some nothing
around us it all just be one thing yeah
and and that's one issue the other issue
is you know let's assume god right yours
God he created the universe did he
create space because if God created
space right just imagine this picture
right what was what did he look like
before there was no space what gave him
she I mean he was Infinite I mean he was
a block an infinite block of whatever
that's that was God
you know and suddenly he creates space
now he looks like a human he's oh thank
god a greeted space alright well then
it's not something then it's not
something because all some things are
imagined but that's how you define right
and and then the option is for the other
guy did you find a word something object
thing whatever you want to call it he's
got to define the term what do you mean
by thing what do you mean by something
what do you mean by object and people
like kind of floating the vagueness and
metaphor because they don't have to
commit to something that can be taken
down by some train of logic right and
this is the primest a nebulous like God
is unimaginable yeah but what does that
mean that means you can't even draw him
for that same reason yeah that's one
issue but the other issues that I won't
be able to follow his presentation
because the guy hasn't told me what
something is you know if he can't tell
me what something is and then he says
and God is something or God is nothing
or God is a concept or or if he's
intelligent or what he is the
intelligence of your cetera and you say
well you know I cannot imagine God
please drawing for me why I can't draw
him because I don't know what he looked
like and if I could draw him then he
wouldn't be so super powerful and bla
bla bla so they have all these arguments
and you say well I can't follow your
presentation because I still don't know
what you mean when every time you
pronounce the word God please define the
term or broader the object or what it do
something but you know otherwise I can't
follow your presentation it's bigger
picture things we can't just talk about
one thing scientifically without it God
and some religious brothers gonna come
up and say yeah see if you can't define
God if you do not know what God looks
like you if and if you could that means
God is not so powerful because you are
able to identify what or who God is then
obviously that's the argument for why
God is so super powerful because you
can't even draw them you cannot imagine
him you cannot define God he's above
your puny yeah and that's the way they
look at it they say look you know he's
so powerful so so unimaginable and when
we're such puny little ants that we
cannot imagine God but then you have the
same situation by the way you know
though don't put it aside you have the
same situation when they say space-time
a four-dimensional space-time well I
cannot imagine don't try you'll break
your brain you know yeah it's uh it's
not possible the space-time is so big so
unimaginable that we cannot even imagine
it we cannot even picture it we cannot
draw it we you don't even try and so
they they leave like these loose ends
and they say you know all our theories
are based on space-time and you say well
that's your starting point let me look
at space down here you can't where
you're not allowed to let but let's
continue from there on that's what
they're saying and you would be on you
would say imagination trumps everything
I put it in a different way that's the
way I put it if I'm gonna understand
your theory please explain it in in
human terms don't tell me it's
unimaginable and God and space-time
don't tell me that you don't know I need
to understand your theory if you have a
theory then just you know start by
explaining or drawing you know whatever
you're gonna explain if you're gonna say
well you know all this is I cannot even
imagine it I've never seen God I've
never seen space-time I cannot draw it I
cannot imagine it if that's your
starting point we got a problem because
I mean if you cannot imagine for sure
I'm not gonna be able to follow your
theory I'm not gonna understand it
either anyways we continue to borrow
same time same station and we'll see you
then
bye bye